montre moi celui dont la sécurité a
justifié pareilles destructions le
mandalorien et la syrie que mis au monde
la plateforme 10 n'est plus le
sécrétions su fait nous replonger dans
l'univers de star wars avec entre autres
le bébé yoda dreillard du bio doit vous
en demander beaucoup rexam
oui c'est vraiment la folie furieuse que
ce soit des sacs à dos des figurines des
tee-shirts
il y en a pour tout le monde pour tous
les goûts les enfants les parents y a
jamais assez de billets de tout le monde
a besoin d'un an à la maison ou que
jeune je suis dans la deuxième saison
qui vient d'être lancée on retrouve le
mandalorien un chasseur de primes pour
n'hésite pas à tuer s'il le faut sa
mission ramener bébé oda auprès des
siens
la série est encore signé jon favreau un
expert de l'univers de star wars qui est
propulsée à l'om mène au cinéma et à qui
on doit la nouvelle mouture du roi lion
avec le mandalorien il s'amuse avec les
personnages de star wars qu'on croyait
disparue pour les femmes le premier
épisode de la deuxième saison
le réservent de belles surprises
la franchise star wars a généré près de
5 milliards de dollars américains depuis
son acquisition en 2012 par disney mais
est ce que le mandalorien est à la
hauteur des attentes déjà très élevée en
plomb je suis dans cet univers de
western intergalactique et pour les
non-initiés l'univers de star wars les
padawan comme moi on va apprécier la
qualité des effets visuels la beauté des
images par contre le scénario modestie
un petit peu sur ma faim mais demandons
une experte ce qu'elle en a pas c'est
toi parfaite entre l'ancien et le
nouveau avec tant de petites références
cachées que les fans les plus en d'ici
peu apprécié à la fois avec à ces
nouveaux contenus que n'importe qui peut
embarquer dans l'univers j'aime aussi
beaucoup le format qui est une aventure
principale avec des petits cats sur le
côté qui nous gardent toujours un petit
peu sur notre faim pour le prochain
épisode étoiles aux frais de son côté
qu'est ce que dans le passé alexandre je
suis enfant de star wars depuis la
première heure
la première saison m'avaient laissé sur
ma faim je trouve que le scénario est un
petit peu trop long passé condensé même
chose pour l'épisode 1 de la deuxième
saison selon - et j'ai eu de la
difficulté à embarquer avec le bébé yoda
- bb avec des longues oreilles poilus
poster donc moi je déguste mais avec
modération le mandalorien voilà à
découvrir sur dix n'est plus ici nabi
alexandre chartier et louis philippe
ouimet radio canada